see look hush you see the crash site is
in a remote mountain range in the
southern alps like suppose you're on a
difficile difficult it's extremely
difficult to access through treacherous
terrain and at altitude it would be too
dangerous to attempt without an
experienced Mountaineer so Morris
Cardoni has agreed to try to take us in
on what will be an eight-hour journey by
foot we have to move through sections of
dense undergrowth it's pretty tough
going at times overhead we saw police
helicopters flying low over the high
alpine pastures heading towards a scene
of utter horror in fact they did keep
you long Murray says the impact was very
violent that the body of the plane was
pulverized
he says the emergency workers are now
trying to recover the bodies so that
they can be identified by the families
with the light starting to fade finally
we reached the summit and the first
sight of where the Germanwings flight
came down
yeah that's clearly debris
we could see the bright yellow of
lifejackets scattered amongst the
wreckage what looks like part of the
landing gear
hundreds of thousands of tiny fragments
the last traces of the 150 lives that
ended here
or at an altitude here of her own 2,000
meters down there is the crash site you
can make out some of the individual
pieces of debris and you can see the
rescue teams working down there using
helicopters because it is just the only
way that they can access this area it is
so remote it is so difficult for the
search-and-rescue teams to get in here
we wash them working here flying back
and forth in relay until darkness fell
this will be a long and extremely
challenging operation but they know that
it's the only hope of finding the
answers the family so desperately need
KD styler Sky News in the southern alps